20 teal winners all under age 20
$100,000 to drop out of school and
pursue our dreams this is team
Technorati
my name is Thomas Hunt I am 17 years old
and I'm working to cure cancer in total
I walk about 5 miles a day in order to
get to center Research Foundation which
is where I do the majority of my
research I have a grandfather who has
skin cancer right now
my grandfather is very excited to hear
about my research in fact my grandpa
actually gave me my first microscope
when Thomas was I think it was a
freshman in high school 13 years old he
was doing a science fair project he
wanted to look at genetically modified
corn and he didn't have the skills he
didn't have the lab equipment that was
needed for this I volunteered our
researchers for that project after he
did his project he found himself
incredibly interested in science and he
began volunteering in our lab at the age
of 13 our youngest volunteer to date
this we call it the negative ad it's
where we store cells or tissues or
whatever really needs to be kept at
really cold temperatures so this is on a
sterile enclosure with this flap up this
allows us to work with cancer cell lines
without being infected with bacteria
this is the biomech 2000 I began working
with this model had two company called
iconic materials and I've been looking
around for one and I having to talk
about my research to a few friends who
happen to have one that they weren't
using and basically gave it to me
through my research as my own personal
violent really no charge bill so I was
just I think it was just really awesome
and I got really excited to get
immediately
programming assays into it
Thomas is an excellent researcher and
really that's why he fits in so well
here we are very fortunate that we've
been able to recruit extremely talented
researchers Thomas oh hey how are you
doing I'm doing well
Aubrey's been a really big mentor for me
for the past few years a fantastic guy
who's been incredibly kind in helping me
and teach me about cancer teach me about
how lab works and allowing me to use
sense to really do my research there
aren't very many biotech fellows they
were able to that you were able to
impress them as much as you did
apparently so Thomas has been working
here at the sounds Research Foundation
lab for about three years he's a
wonderful person and a great prodigy
obviously when he joined the lab he was
only 13 years old and he's made
significant contributions to various
projects especially the one that he's
been working on for the past couple of
years the project to find how some
cancers made to survive and grow
indefinitely even though they don't turn
on this key enzyme telomerase he is
really exceptional in that he's not
exceptional in other words in that he's
not here to make up the weight he
actually makes the proper contribution
just like people twice his age they
currently have six drugs that I'm
planning on testing and I'm planning now
that I have funding to begin being able
to begin actual tests and hopefully
getting some results
the chemotherapy is kind of a it's a
disgusting manner of trying to fight
cancer I mean you're you're killing
cancer at the same time the person's
absolutely suffering the entire process
the tests that I have been doing I'm
beginning to actually test actual drugs
that are interested in my only concern
is the results could be very erratic
I think 100,000 is a really great start
and it will be able to help me a lot
however I hope to have planned as my
project goes on to get funding from
outside sources as well
thank you they believe very strongly
that you need to pursue exactly what
you're interested immediately and I try
to emphasize that my project where I try
to get the results now because cancer is
not going to wait another 10 years tune
in for the next episode of teen
technorati for our biggest event of the
summer
the teal summit and be sure to subscribe
to the wired Channel